first of all congrats I've seen the
first three episodes and if I had
episode four five and six I would have
already watched
so I have to I like starting with a fun
question and it's gonna be at you you
recently worked with Celine Dion uh what
is it like being able to text Celine
Dion yeah I mean I feel like I really
arrived it's really cool especially when
she responds
because you can text people you know but
when they respond to you and Celine
actually sent me a responded response I
was like wow I actually know her now
that's an achievement no she's
incredible she's amazing so this the
series of six episodes which is the
episode that you guys are most looking
forward to fancying it's gonna be sex
yeah I plant so many seeds throughout
the show and jump through so many
timelines everything collides and all
the payoffs happen in the sixth episode
I mean every episode has a big chunk of
the journey but I love episode six and
you agree um I would say that
that's a hard one to pick but I have to
agree with Richard like so much so many
questions get answered and you have so
many other questions by episode six
because you're so invested in everyone's
stories that I feel like sixes and
there's some amazing Revelations to look
forward to so one of the things that
really I was impressed with was the
first episode because you guys were
staging movie style action on a TV show
that is not easy to accomplish so could
you for both of you could you sort of
talk about doing an action set piece
like that right from the beginning and
setting up you know this big thing and I
think the Russo's at the helm of that
makes it easy because they can do this
better than anyone I think for me it was
it was great for that to kick off the
show because as an actor you get
informed by these big sequences were
thrown into like who are these people
how do they interact physically verbally
what's the the stakes of their life and
situation how do they handle the
environment they're in so it was kind of
it was daunting but it may makes you
make decisions about who these people
are and try to show the audience
um who these two are together their
relationship from the very beginning
you're thrust into their world what was
it like for you I think that's what was
exciting about it for me um I mean I'm a
features girl I love movie Magic and to
be able to now in this changing
environment where people are consuming
their media and that's fortunate or
unfortunate on their tablets on their
phones you know um and streamers give
people access around the world so the
pro of it is that people are being able
to access entertainment from everywhere
anywhere
um and I guess you know I that's what's
really exciting to me is to be able to
this is a big old movie it's like six
episodes It's a movie we've shot it like
a movie and it's just been spliced up so
it's like a movie on your TV I think
it's like it's very cool one of the
things that I'm actually really looking
forward to about the series is that
there is an Italian version in an Indian
version uh and it's all interconnected
but I just like that it's a world show
so can I have to ask are you are your
characters making an appearance on those
other two series again
blink if it's true I'm not going to
Blink
um no I I hope so I hope we get to do
some crossover things you know
let's Tuscany I feel like this
would be nice to pop into
um there are stories and threads that
get pulled we can't really specifically
speak to that but there are like things
that you'll feel
um you and you can watch all of them by
themselves and not feel the need to
connect them but if you choose to it'll
be really a fun little nugget you know
that you'll find all over I enjoy both
of your work and I'm curious and I
always like asking actors this question
um if you have a huge dramatic or
emotional scene on say a Monday morning
how early on are you actually preparing
to film that scene are you doing it as
soon as you get the script is it over
the weekend where you really start laser
focusing if you could both just maybe
take me through your process a little
bit
sometimes there's changes on every job I
suppose everything kind of and and time
time and days cease to exist when you're
filming release so Monday morning might
as well be Thursday evening for all the
as you you kind of have all these scenes
all these moments and the character in
your head all the time just kind of like
soup
um and if they just kind of until you
have to engage with that moment I think
sometimes if you overthink these things
you um you can mess it up by kind of
over preparing for that I mean Priyanka
is brilliant at being beautifully
present she can just grab something and
engage with it
um but I think it comes from what you're
saying is like we're so familiar you
like at least my process is that and
working with Richard I feel like that's
how he works too is familiarize so much
yourself with your character that it's
not you don't have to think about a
scene you just know this person so well
you know how they're going to react when
they're put in a situation what their
um reaction will be to someone what
their reaction will be to an environment
so whatever is thrown at them it's never
an isolated emotion anyway you can't be
like I'm angry or I'm sad there's
multiple things that are happening so
it's just informed because you know the
parameters of your character I think and
that no no need to go I'm just going to
say can't wait to see the rest of the
series good luck we should be dating